[Music]
we will be starting the webinar in about
five minutes
we are currently playing background
music so if you can't hear any
background music please
shoot
and if you need any technical assistance
just reach us through the chat module
see you soon
[Music]
do
so hello to everyone joining us on
facebook if you would like to join us
over here on zoom
please click on the link in the comments
so thank you everybody for joining us
for our webinar today to our city with
love today's session is brought to you
by design singapore council the national
agency for design in singapore in
partnership with center for livable
cities deloitte center for the edge
participate in design and the urban
redevelopment authority in support of
the singapore together movement
this event is also part of the national
design center's program lineup in august
and september with a thematic focus on
singapore our home
so when you entered the webinar you may
have noticed a few polls on your screen
through the polls we are hoping to get a
broad sense of how everyone here views
loveability in singapore
so if you have not had the chance to
take the poll please complete it now
we will be sharing the results of the
poll later during the discussion
we proceed i would like to highlight a
few housekeeping notes which you can see
on this screen
so do note that um the session is being
recorded
if you encounter any technical issues
you can reach our technical team
through the zoom check function
and we ask for your patience and
understanding should conditions be less
than perfect
during this webinar your audio will be
on mute by default
however we welcome questions anytime
during the session
using the zoom q and a function and if
you look on the screen now you can see
where that would be
now when you're posing a question could
you please state your name where you're
from
and if you have a specific panelist that
you'd like to respond to your question
let us know as well
all right and with this we would like to
kick off this evening's program with
opening remarks by mr mark lee executive
director of the design singapore council
so mr mark b is a design thinking
pioneer in singapore having designed
award-winning innovative experiences for
the public and private sector
as a design veteran with wide industry
connections mark has brought the work of
the council to the attention of global
design leaders
he is uh he is by training an architect
who was recognized by the urban
redevelopment authority in 2017
as the top 20 under 45 architects in
singapore that would redefine the next
generation
and now please welcome mark for the
opening remarks
well hello everyone hi
um hopefully y'all can
hi hi everyone um
so good evening just uh thank you all
for um
just coming on board
uh
good evening everyone kind of well
welcome to uh our webinar
uh to our city with love
um
as you know this is actually the first
of a two-part series of
exploring what a lovable singapore
actually means to us
uh so i like janine shared i'm mark the
executive director of the design
singapore council
i'm super happy and welcome to
um
we y'all to to see that tonight there's
such a diverse kind of audience from
singapore and also beyond our shows i
understand that today actually
we have guests from europe
australia korea and other asian cities
as well
and
thank you for all joining us this
evening
a number of guests be
joining us for the first time so i'd
like to just take a few moments to
actually introduce the the council and
what we actually do
as a national agency for design
our vision is actually for singapore to
be an innovation driven economy and a
lovable city through design
our work actually focuses on three areas
first we have organizations and
enterprises actually use design as a
strategy to grow businesses and deliver
people-centered public services
secondly
what we do is we nurture industry-ready
talent
and actually enable a design-minded
workforce for the future economy
and the third we actually advance the
singapore brand through raising design
appreciation
on home ground and making emotion
hopefully emotional connections with
people across the world for example
through a seminar like
through a webinar like this tonight
uh the question of what makes a city
lovable is actually very close to our
hearts at the council
this is also a question that's been
actually increasingly important around
the world
and we've heard the statistics right
today are about 55 of the world's
population lives actually in urban areas
and by 2050 two thirds of the global
population will actually live in cities
according to the u.n
along with that we are facing
increasingly complex what we so-called
we call wicked problems like climate
change aging population and economic
recession as a result of geopolitical
uncertainties
and the emotional connections we have
with the places we and the spaces we
live in will be crucial we feel in
galvanizing resilience engagement and
collaboration actually to come together
to find creative solutions so hence we
are very very interested in how a
lovable city is actually designed and
how we can design a lovable singapore
in fact this is actually encapsulated in
our design master plan 2025 we could
which you could download online
and the master plan if not if you have
not looked through it was actually put
together by
a committee comprising first our policy
makers design and business leaders who
actually came together to craft a vision
of singapore's future by design
of which would be an innovation driven
economy and a lovable city
and while we have indices to actually
map and measure our progress towards an
innovation driven economy we actually
have yet to articulate a shared vision
for
a lovable city
and this is actually our council's goal
to actually investigate what a lovable
singapore could look like to all of us
and together a group of like-minded
people from the public and private
sector to investigate this with us
over the last past few months our
council has actually worked with other
public agencies such as the urban
redevelopment authority the ura the
singapore together secretary under the
ministry of culture community and youth
and the center for livable cities
as well as consultancies like deloitte's
center for the age and participate in
design
and together we actually began to
process the the process of engaging
groups of people in singapore about this
topic itself
we posed ourselves actually two key
research questions
about for this top for this project
first
what do we
love about singapore
and second what will make us love
singapore more
and to this end we've actually run four
focus group sessions spoken to experts
across the fields of our arts
heritage design business and academia
and interviewed singaporeans permanent
residences and long-time residences of
singapore
we've actually uncovered insights that
both confirm our hypothesis
as well as those that have intrigued and
challenged us
some of earlier of our earlier findings
have actually shown us that we need to
expand our definition of lovability
the breadth of stories that we received
have been actually remarkable
from the 20-something-year-old student
who told us he loves our transport
system because of the sense of adventure
it gives him in assessing so many areas
of singapore to the older couple who
told us how well designed a streetscape
is that someone loved it enough to do a
good job
and people spoke about their love for
the mature trees around the city the
sense of neighborliness and the ability
to make a significant impact on society
we've also heard stories about how much
more work singapore has to do in
achieving a truly inclusive society
elderly folk who are feeling
marginalized in terms of technology
language and accessibility of public
spaces
and new citizens who are unsure what
role they actually can play here on the
island so the sheer diversity of
viewpoints have actually both inspired
and galvanized us to expand our outreach
to more people and thus gather more
voices
and some of our participants have asked
us bluntly what is the point of asking
people
about loveability in a time such as this
in the middle of a pandemic and a global
recession
and this is a question we have asked
ourselves as well
undoubtedly the current crisis has both
thrown into relief the best and worst of
human nature around the world
it is especially laid bare the huge
social and economic inequalities that
already exist
in singapore we saw this most clearly
with problems around our foreign worker
dormitories
and however we also saw the most
impressive ground-up
community-driven efforts by groups like
the covet-19 migrant support coalition
as well as other types of projects like
mars sewn with love
with the design within the design
community many have also stepped up to
donate time resources and their design
skills to enhance safe practices share
knowledge and boost morale for example
there's a campaign called thank you
delivery heroes
which was appreciative posters for
delivery workers by a local creative
agency kinetic
and numerous designers also went about
sewing or 3d printing masks and shields
which they generously donated
so this
their form might not be the most
convenient time to ask what we love
about singapore and how we can make it
more lovable however it is an extremely
important time to do so we feel
it is a time to ask ourselves some
honest questions about how we stand
together
as a community
and reassess what is important to us
collectively and frame our local
identity culture heritage and bonds
if we believe that lovable cities are
the ones that are inclusive community
driven and resilient then there's really
no time like the present to ask
ourselves if singapore is truly
lovable for everyone and what we can do
to make it more so especially for groups
that are less hurt from
so i'm heartened that these are the very
topics our panelists and moderators are
here to discuss this evening
and we got leaders from the world of
arts and culture
social enterprise research and think
tanks
and i'm excited for super robust
boundary pushing discussion
and i'm also really looking forward to
hearing our audience's thoughts as well
during the polls and q and a later
so with this i'd love to hand the time
over to our extreme panelists and i wish
everyone a very of course lovable
evening
thanks
thank you mark
so before we launch into our panel
discussion i would just like to briefly
share more
about the lovable singapore study that
design singapore council is driving
together with our collaborating partners
so when we first started on this project
and started talking to stakeholders and
interested parties about what they find
lovable about singapore the most
recurring question people asked us was
what do you mean by love so after
several similar such conversations it
became clear to us that one important
task we have
would be to unpack and articulate the
definition of love how love is felt and
expressed between people and the place
they live in
the diversity of viewpoints and the
breadth of the topic make this a
challenging task but as mark just
mentioned also a very necessary one in
these times
another driving motivator behind the
project is that although our initial
surveys found that most respondents find
singapore very livable
singapore is clearly not lovable to
everyone
in fact it might even be unlovable to
many people at some point in their lives
so we want to delve deeper more deeply
into
what these pain points are are they an
inevitable aspect of living in a dense
fast-paced environment
or is this something we can make lovable
by design
and so besides drawing together an
articulation of lovability our other
goal is also to uncover insights that
would help us identify opportunities to
make singapore more livable
and so the lovable singapore project is
in two parts the first is a
comprehensive study with singaporeans
and singapore residents
this will launch in october and run
until december
aiming to engage more than 2000 people
the second part of the project is to
then translate the findings of the study
into insights that can create meaningful
actionable outcomes
in terms of projects programs and
prototypes and we hope to launch this
early next year
so how can you take part well first we
need your voices
so please start by taking part in our
polls and the q and a segment tonight
if we can't get your questions tonight
we are actually going to invite our
panelists to share their answers post
webinar and
we will in turn share these on our
website and through social media
also please do join us for the second
webinar of this series where we will
officially launch the study and invite
everyone's participation
so this will be on the 30th of september
and we will share more details at the
end of this webinar
all right so with that let's move on to
tonight's program and allow me to
introduce our speakers first is our
moderator mr delisha kulasria
executive director of deloitte center
for the edge
delisha is the lead strategist for
deloitte's center for the edge a
research institute exploring the edges
of business and technology
over the past decade they have explored
how the world is changing in very
dramatic ways as a result of ever
evolving digital infrastructure
and changing public policy
and they explore the implications on us
as individuals and institutions
joining him today on today's panel we
have three wonderfully diverse panelists
so first miss ivontam chief executive
officer of the esplanade
yvonne has been at the esplanade since
2014 overseeing its strategic and social
objectives as a performing arts center
for everyone
she also serves on the board of nanyang
academy of fine arts cystic.com
the council of the association of asia
pacific performing arts centers
singapore film commission advisory
committee
and the urban redevelopment authority's
heritage and identity panel
next we have mr tongi
executive director of common ground
he is the co-founder of singapore's
largest group of social enterprises that
focuses on building social and emotional
capital in singapore
so these comprise thought collective
school of thought think tank studio food
for thought and common ground
his works span across innovative place
making projects curriculum design
organizational design change management
and innovation
he is also currently part of a number of
national committees including families
for life council and singapore discovery
center
finally we have miss lauren sorkin
executive director of the global
resilient cities network
lauren oversees global efforts to
strengthen cities in the face of complex
and interconnected challenges
she is on the advisory board of several
sustainability focused initiatives
including food tank
the singapore sustainability summit and
natural capital
she also serves as an advisor and
spokesperson on topics like urban
resilience
women's leadership sustainable finance
climate risk stakeholder engagement and
urbanization trends
so welcome all speakers
and now over to you delisha
hello
can everyone hear me
yes i can hear you i'm evolving okay
great
uh good evening everyone it's great to
be here it's great to be part of this
discourse
uh thank you janine thank you mark
and i want to um
talk to her about like how we'd want to
spend the next hour plus with everyone
here on in the group a little bit more
context to myself and center for the
edge like janine mentioned i'm the
executive director of center for the age
for asia pacific
i just moved to singapore last year from
san francisco i've been in the u.s for
many years and ran the center for the
edge in part for the last 12 years
and
came out here to singapore last year to
start the center for the edge in asia
pacific and
we are called the center for the edge
because we believe that all uh
disruptions emerge from the edge and
that's what we explore so for lack of a
better term we're like futurists
and but singapore isn't by happenstance
we moved here we choose to move here
because we have a strong affinity to
this i've been traveling back and forth
to singapore for many years now
but my wife happens to be singaporean so
this is in part our return to asia i
grew up in sri lanka
and to be
much more part of this part of the world
which i believe
is an edge
demographically and geographically that
the rest of the world can learn from
i have an amazing panel here with tony
ivan and lauren what we'd like to do
today
is to stretch this topic of lovability
i got engaged in this topic because
we've done some similar work in the u.s
looking at some of these up and coming
cities like pittsburgh looking to see
what could make these cities more
livable lovable and so i've been part of
this journey for a couple of months now
with dsg
as an external advisor but at this point
we're taking this public we're taking
this to all of you we want your input
this webinar is going to have some
limited ways of getting input that we
had a poll at the beginning we'll have
another poll at the end please put in
your questions if you can we'll try and
answer them today if we can't answer
them today we'll answer them at a later
point but we really want your input into
this
so here's how the next hour plus is
going to go um
we'll start off by getting to our
panelists give them kind of a basic
question like we did with you but
they're here for very specific reasons
so we're going to delve a little deeper
into each of their perspectives that we
can bring together we want them to
challenge we want them to go beyond the
obvious
and let's see if collectively
we can figure out how to make singapore
a more lovable place
so
i have an easy question for everyone if
anything around love is easy to start
off with our panelists and tangy i'm
going to start with you first
and i'm going to go to each of the
fantasy the same question but
what does lovability mean to you
and there's a follow-up to that
if not singapore which country might be
more most lovable to you
right
lovability uh
how much time do we have so
the short answer is
um
lovability for me is really not about
you know uh cute big eyed animals or
um
something yourself that i adore or
something i'm fascinated with i think
loveability around is really about
relationship for me um it's about the
quality the relationship the quality of
the trust relationship
um
and whether or not i feel that i am i
think the words i find over here is
whether i feel constituted of whether i
feel a part of
something
so that's a real
important part that when i enter into a
city or enter into a space whether or
not i feel connection with the space um
and that's what typically makes me feel
loved yeah
and is there a city that you like that
would come to mind
as most lovable for you
uh
i think what's fascinating for me over
here is this whole idea of um
if you ask me about cape town london uh
istanbul as cities
i love them all
as in fact i'm in love with them but
whether or not i can claim to love them
i think it's another thing
um i was just reflecting over the idea
of the distinction between a
relationship with a wife or or a
mistress
yes i do recall that conversation
yeah but it was interesting over here
because i do a lot of marriage mediation
and um
people often times over here say that in
the relationships that they have within
the marriages sometimes the marriages
shadows are created and they start to
create uh they start to look for you
know
other relationships that can satisfy
this particular shadow
and i think when i go to cape town
istanbul london i i tend to actually
start experiencing a very different life
that i would in singapore i have this
illusion i'm i'm in love with this
with these cities but if you ask me like
whether or not i truly love singapore i
think my commitment is really here
um so i could be in love with others but
really my relationship is is with
singapore yeah so do you okay very good
so
it's a great way to start us off this
you bring a distinction between being in
love and loving and the commitment and
the relationship and the trust and being
part of that's required for that so
let's take the same question to you
yvonne
what uh does lovability mean to you in
the context of a city
and if not singapore is another city
that comes to mind we need a love
ability
yeah we are mute
sorry this is like classic um
zoom chime statement right oh no i was
just saying i love how tongy spoke about
wife and mistress simply because for the
men you know that that just means
sorry i don't want to make this gendered
but
i when that first question was posed to
me or when i you know mark and you guys
asked me to report this i'm like how do
you talk about love if you do not speak
of love in the context of a relationship
so i do agree with you because you know
it's not the same as saying you know i
love a glass of wine i love this
restaurant um
but you know
any relationship or anything that we
talk about that is of meaning of value
you go back to that very prime
covenant right so be it a marriage file
or your partner or
you know your the love between a mother
and a child so that that to me is
uh very very core and to me lovability
says as much about the lover as it is
about the beloved so you always look for
it reflects actually your values right
so you look for in your lover or your
beloved whatever it may be
those same values that you seek for
yourself so i would say when we look at
the city
it says very much about
who we are as a people by what we say we
love about that city um and and it is
this dynamic right the city is not a
kind of an object or something that is
uh fixed it is constantly reflecting and
relating back to its lover oh it's
beloved so my my question oftentimes
when when this first uh when you guys
speak of livability of the city who is
the lover of the city and who who does
the city love you know does the city
love the folks with who's parking their
wealth here or does the city love
you know it's citizens does it city love
who does the city love
and i think that then tells how
decisions are made for that city
uh if i have a city that i love other
than singapore it will be
taipei
um
a
very simple reason i go there every year
with my late husband so it's got
memories of love for me
but also i think it's a city that you
know people have fought very hard to
love
if you go to that city you know it's
been defined by citizens or people who
who chose partly because of the threat
of china of course uh to to say how it's
different right so it's different
because of its nature
it's different because of um
its history you know it's a city that
constantly has to say why it needs to
exist and why it needs to be different
and its people want it to be so
and
you can see that everywhere and it's
public transport in its uh
public sector advertisements in the
public transport you speak to anyone on
the street you know they can hate them
they can complain about the government
but
everything they do is because they
really love that city you know if you
meet a stranger in the streets yeah i
remember our first trip to taipei we
bought a pair of shoes and the guy who's
selling us the pair of shoes just meant
i'm going to go up the mountains on my
motorbike you know it's my favorite
place in the city do you want to come
along
now if if you if you are not in love
with your girlfriend or boyfriend or
your husband or your mistress for that
matter you're going to hide them in the
shadows but if you love somebody you
just want to show it off you want to go
everywhere with that person you you want
to do everything with that person and
you want to post photos of that person
on your instagram you know
that that to me is a sign of
why
and that love is very infectious
yeah
so it seems like there's a lot of
barrels between
singapore and taipei in some ways the
reasons to exist and all of that
um it also seems like you're you're
mirroring what
uh tong yi said about a relationship a
two-way thing it's not about just you
loving them but the city loving you back
and indicating what it loves by its
behavior and what it does
um excellent so i'm going to come back
to some of those points when you when
you get to us lauren can we pull you in
as the
outsider but also insider to singapore
you should also talk about your
connection to singapore
what makes uh
what does liability mean to you
and uh if not singapore
what might be most liable to you
thanks delisha i mean despite the fact
that you and i might look different or
sound different we actually have much
more in common in terms of our
relationship with singapore then it
might seem at the surface because um for
me i actually fell in love with the
singaporean before i fell in love with
singapore
so i've been coming back and forth to
singapore for
um
you know for way more than a decade now
and
we decided to
headquarter the global resilient cities
network which is a network that looks at
systemic resilience and how we make
cities stronger safer and more equitable
and more lovable in many ways
um based here because of the incredible
story that singapore has in the
incredible capacity that singapore has
so it's been um a fantastic journey um
to get here um and
i think when we look at cities and their
loveability
we we start off not unlike we'd start
any relationship so to fall in love you
need to be excited and you need to see
some kind of opportunity
so if a city is not going to reel you in
with you know some exciting
food some exciting skyline some exciting
art scene you know you might not end up
there in the first place or if there's
not opportunity right so many of us move
uh because of jobs because of what we're
looking for and so for that initial
spark
you need excitement and you need
opportunity but then what is enduring
and i i think um tony and yvonne have
talked about this in a really beautiful
way there has to be
that
maturation right from the excitement the
spark and the opportunity to a
relationship with your city that is one
of trust
um that's one of admiration and that is
one of mutual contribution and i think
there's a lot more we could talk about
in relationship to this because it's not
just you know what our cities can do for
us but what we can do for our cities and
where we feel
that we're given the opportunity to
participate and contribute in
this love right and and what we make of
our cities because cities
by definition are actually
gatherings of people in concentrated
areas
because we're pursuing some kind of
common economic or common social purpose
so
um you know what we need for cities to
be lovable
is for them to foster this kind of trust
and for some people that means you know
like the
the gentleman was talking about before
in the opening when mark was talking
about maybe that means reliable
infrastructure to some people being able
to trust that your city is going to take
care of you can get from point a to
point b safely um maybe that trust means
that when you fall on hard times your
city has a social safety net right and
that's going to take care of you and i
think that in particular right now
um you know in covet 19 that is so
important that people think that they're
going to be taken care of
um and then finally that
you know that interplay right so what
can i do in my city can i be an active
participant in shaping the future right
in bringing
that idea right or bringing that
excitement back into the city and does
the city have a place for me in that in
that future so that's what i would say
and you know i think singapore has a lot
to offer uh in in those spaces i've
certainly come to love singapore very
much um and i think as
um
you know
as a professional
the idea
um
i said i would say the cornucopia of
ideas that's available in singapore
is a pretty impressive one
we can't take advantage of it now but
the gateway to you know southeast asia
south asia east asia is a phenomenal um
lovability aspect
but even in these times of trouble
the sense of community
um and the ability to know that you will
be taken care of that
you do have um institutions that are
looking out for you and providing for
your family um and that you know the
schools will go on the transport will go
on you know these are realities that
many around the world are grappling with
right now and the results have been
um
uh rather less
less appealing
no it's we are different in very strange
times with a double whammy of a pandemic
and a global recession
and singapore a lot of people
confidently feel is a place that will
love you back in this context and will
take care of you
and this is a longitudinal study we want
to do so it'd be interesting to see as
time goes on how that might differ
and you're right you've been here longer
but you and i both made choices to be
here so that does say that we are
willing to take on the good and the bad
with this it's very interesting now i
know we talked about this before and i'm
going to come back to you on this again
country you got to pick your child at
least is there a country that
immediately comes to mind and that's
something we can explore more with you
as well
yeah so when you and i talked about this
before i said it's very difficult for me
to pick a city there are 97 incredible
and progressive cities in our network
and it sometimes feels like being asked
to pick a favorite child
um so i i will just say that there are
some cities that i think do lovability
very well
i think kyoto is a fantastic example of
building on history embracing the future
you know whether it's just food or manga
or
really trying to draw people in and re
constantly reinvent itself on the back
of a completely rich and inspiring
history um
in terms of you know little cities that
could i think there's a lot to love
about penang and malacca
um and
uh where they are in their journey as
cities and um i think i would
i would uh
i i would be
not being very truthful if i didn't say
that both new york and barcelona for me
are are cities that you know i have
spent a lot of time in um having grown
up on the east coast of the us and lived
in in new york that
have that opportunity and that sense of
energy and openness
uh and possibility that i think makes
them incredibly lovable and and allows
them to keep reinventing themselves in
the face of uh difficulty
yeah so and i think the the discourse
we're having now and the study we're
doing the dsc is running
will have broad implications i'd love to
test it with these other cities as well
but uh at this point i'd like to take a
pause and bring the audience in
and so when you came in when the
audience came in that a polling question
that three questions can we pop up their
answers and see how they responded to a
similar question
so let's see the first question was on a
scale of zero to five how lovable is
singapore
and uh we got 32 with three 49 percent
with four ten percent at five and no
zeros or ones and you know two people or
six percent
saying not so allowable um this actually
mirrors the study that we when when when
mark and jeanine said we kind of reached
out at the beginning it mirrors that a
lot um so
pretty high a high leading towards a
lovable space now let's think about why
or why not that's a second and third
question this would be a little tougher
can we go to the next two
okay let me move my screen here
so here the question was what are some
important factors that make singapore
lovable or unlovable for you at the same
list and we said what's lovable and what
big two that makes it loud when i pick
two that makes it unlovable let's look
at this for a second
so safety and security makes it lovable
in current context absolutely understand
that
personal agents and civic participation
tony this is your space is what makes it
most
unlovable
second place for lovable would be family
and friends
okay that's that's great
and then a lot of thirties uh values and
culture physical environment
memories and nostalgia future potential
um
okay on the unlovable side winning by a
large margin is personal agent civic
participation
and number two is values and culture
interesting okay
physical environment is 30 that's
surprising
and
the rest are kind of low memories in
nostalgia future potential
um i invite any of the panelists to
comment on these anything surprising
here
i don't think they're too surprising
actually talisha i think
the conversation um
that you and i had ahead of this this
panel and then what i talked about in
the third point of that mutual
um
support that that really
seems like it resonates with this
audience that ability to have personal
agency and participate in the shape of
the city um seems like such a missed
opportunity
in in singapore and one that is ready to
be harnessed in a lot of ways
um
it's
it's something you hear a lot i hear a
lot i think when i uh talk to younger
singaporeans and i've had the privilege
of speaking at a lot of different events
for nus or ntu and smu as well and
i'm
consistently impressed
by the knowledge um and these tend to be
folks who are in the urban planning
sphere or economics or sustainability
the the knowledge that students have and
so to have that level of capacity
especially when you consider where
singapore is sitting in the region we do
a lot of work across asean and just by
comparison let's say that
the statistics show about
60 of the people who are working in
government
in secondary cities
which are the fastest growing in
indonesia haven't finished a college
degree
and then you have this amazing capacity
and level of engagement and desire to
engage here in singapore and people
don't feel like they have the
opportunity so i think there's there's a
there's a desire and there's this
incredible untapped potential for for
this lovability work
so we saw that someone as an outsider
observer from the general elections this
year but i want to put on you into this
conversation this is your domain where
you dedicated your life and your work to
this for the last many years
what is your take on this
it's interesting i was looking at the
pinks
safety and security personal agency and
plastic partition and future potential
and i'm seeing a sort of polarity there
i know that uh right now in the season
of where singapore is and the phase of
development is i know there's a lot of
energy on the government's part to try
and co-create and co-collaborate
together with i guess
people as much as possible
um but i do know itself that there is
that that struggle i guess i mean if we
go back to the metaphor of the
relationship
the struggle between the parent that
says when do i let go and if i do let go
you know and i don't control the
out of my kid um
you know is my kid gonna do his own
duties is he you know do i dare let him
fail
and
it's interesting over here because i
think even right now in the social and
civic side there are multiple
organizations that are stepping up uh to
i guess fill the gaps and try to
actually just self-solve you know
self-create our own civic solutions
um but
if i were to be honest over here many
organizations are not at the scale at
which the government can therefore begin
to fill this particular gap
so if they were to pull back the
question is whether we have the ability
to scale as quickly or as effectively as
you know there's a question
there's a question of maturity
there's a question of maturity about the
ground up
capability to fill in the gap
if the if the parents were to step
i'm not so sure about maturity i i my
sense over here is that as far as the
knowledge and concepts and experience is
concerned the maturity is there capacity
i'm not so sure yeah capacity okay
capacity yeah
um so there's a question here from the
audience i want to bring back uh from
louis louis here why
do we need to love singapore
is that even a requirement i mean it's a
little bit different and we wanted to
talk about it before it's a little bit
different from kind of a a choice that
you make with a lover or a wife or a
mistress or whichever you choose to a
girlfriend boyfriend where it's a choice
right here you're born to it it is
not a choice it's kind of been born into
a family that is who you have to deal
with so is there do we need to love
singapore as a question
no but i think these are themes that
sorry ivan
no no no please go ahead
i'll i'll do a very quick one um
i think these are themes that actually
both evolved lauren have actually
brought up earlier that love has a lot
to do with resilience love has a lot to
do with commitment uh
in our our world we often say it's not
that those who are passionate are the
willing sufferer
that we know someone itself is
impassioned when they're willing to
suffer right and they're willing itself
right to put in i guess
um
the pedal to the metal yeah
and in doing so over here i think that's
that's that's really something where i'm
i think that is real strong uh
i would say even economic value as far
as love is concerned um without regards
to you know not having brain drain
keeping basically your talent within
your country coming to a space over here
where if a crisis happens that we are
willing itself right to to commit um to
do what's necessary itself right to get
us back on track
um and this is a lot to do yourself with
whether we love our cities yeah yvonne
sorry sorry i'm not just listening to
both of you speak i think one of the
issues
uh that is voiced or unvoiced here is
that there is a conflation between the
city the country and our political
culture
and that i think is at the heart of this
that there is the desire not to love
because i don't love the pap or the
government whichever the government of
the day is
um
and
the government may provide the security
but you know it's not providing
the personal agency or the levels of
civic participation i so desire so i i
find that there is
sometimes among singaporeans because of
dominance of a
political language and it's a political
language that has started from a day of
our political independence
that has
in some ways colored our view of what is
society what is the culture
what is public discourse and therefore
what is singapore and i think you know
that that really needs to be addressed
and i'm also very conscious because i i
did ask the organizers who's in this
conversation and i have a sneaking
suspicion that we're going to have
kind of quite a couple of uh public
servants in this conversation and that
to me is troubling uh when public
servants uh say there is
no sense of personal agency and and
civic participation because you set that
tone i mean um
you know and there is a question for
melanie here who is the city the city
council the people
that this really gets at the heart of um
the maturity or immaturity will of our
society that there is some sense that um
it is conflated with a dominant
political culture and a lack of
understanding
with the diversity of that language the
diversity of voiceless and how you can
participate politically or maybe not
politically socially culturally um
vis-a-vis that political culture so to
me that feels like something that gets
at the heart of that love if you will
you know um
yeah this is a very good point and so we
dsg is a semi-governmental entity and
talking on language
one of the questions or the the
subtitles of this whole thing is
a lovable city by design
can you even create a lovable city by
design or is that oxymoron on its own
can you force someone to love you
okay or do you can you create the
conditions
in such
well again you know i i guess because
dsg is a public sector it reflects a
certain degree of governance
and you know um and how do you create
environments that reflect the values of
that culture i know values and culture
kind of sits in this very awkward space
of 31 lovable and 57 unlovable so it
means that there is to me the ones where
it's not so clear-cut
where there is some sense of tension and
what do we understand by values and
culture
how much of that values and culture is
determined by official speak and uh
public bodies and and folks in authority
how much of that values and culture is
kind of ground up and i think that's
where the the attention may be
um
yeah
okay so i want to get to a few other
topics uh please do keep sending the
questions to some really good questions
i'm going to come back to this
uh we had the word resilience mentioned
a couple of times and this is lauren's
um domain of expertise uh you like you
said you're 97 cities a global resilient
city network
what's the connection between resilience
and liability
so
resilience the way we define it for the
urban form is the ability for everyone
from the citizen
up to the business and then the
institutions in the system of the city
to survive adapt and to thrive no matter
what kind of shock or stress you might
face
so
inherent in that definition
is a real holistic
look at a city and and what it will do
and in the same sense when
when we think about love we think about
the whole right of the person of the
city and we also acknowledge flaws along
with strong points right we don't ignore
them
right and we we love in spite of them
and we work on supporting them and
that's very similar to resilience
practice
because you are only as resilient as the
weakest point in your system
and similarly in a relationship right
you you are only going to be able to
love as far as you can understand and
overcome those difficulties so
um
i think this is it's so interesting to
hear about you know the different
ways that you can
pull apart some of the results of this
survey and the others that you've done
because singapore in so many ways is a
system of systems
right you have a national system layered
on essentially what geographically is is
a city system right and we see similar
things happening in other city states um
so
you you look at this and you have to say
well
what
about my system
is weak right is is it my leadership in
institutions is it my physical
environment is it the interplay between
those
and you have to see
what's happening at that whole level and
then address it and and prioritize and
you have to do that with a lot of love
the other thing that's very common to
resilience and love is that medium
long-term view right this is not a
short-term gain you cannot build
resilience with band-aids
impossible
you cannot build on quicksand right you
actually have to set a solid foundation
so there has to be a common
understanding and that's the last point
that i would leave it with which is that
both love and resilience rest on having
a very clear-eyed view
of your current starting point you have
to know where you are in order to build
resilience you have to know where you
are in order to build loveability you
can't be building it based on any kind
of false pretenses or false advertising
or the profile picture that you saw once
on the dating app and you happen to
swipe one way versus the other it is a
much
longer term deeper commitment
so it's a great answer and again
bringing back to a human relationship
idea
people change times change so you might
get together in one context but then
times do change countries change people
like
uh
communities change everything like
there's an evolution to it so the thing
you mentioned about a long-term point of
view brings to uh mine
one of the prior conversations tongki
having the infrastructure
the the bones
uh singapore having good bones but then
talking about her tongue can you can you
expand on that the analogy brought
forward there
you often use the analogy of um
bones organs and flesh and blood
but singapore as far as bones are
concerned that's the infrastructure
right organs are your institution
and i think we built some pretty solid
institutions and pretty solid
infrastructure um but at our second
phase of development we really are into
issues of flesh and blood
who is flesh of my flesh who is blood of
my blood
and the whole question itself that we
ask us is that success will naturally
breed diversity right as long as you're
successful diversity will come people
will come to be a part of the city they
will flock into the city over here and i
think we have huge inclusion issues
right now over a question of who is a
part of us and who is not a part of us
right
uh and these inclusion issues i think
they are uh incredibly difficult to to
talk about um
i was taking a bit of what lauren was
saying even what you think i noticed
that there's one thing i hope this
doesn't distract too much
um
but i just have to say it if there's one
thing itself i can't personally stand
about singapore is that because we've
designed ourselves so successful that we
have we can't blemish it we can't talk
about the suicide i mean can't talk
about the homelessness and we can't talk
about basically whatever is going on
over there and every time itself i bring
it up they will euthanize it for god's
sake so
yeah and we don't express the
vulnerability there is no space for
citizens to grow only when the
vulnerability is expressed then there's
a space for civic action civic capacity
to come in and fill that particular
space but we'd have to be able to name
it
right and not put ourselves as perfect
as we are because we're not right
obviously every relationship is going to
have an issue right now a shadow of some
kind
i completely completely agree
and i i've been a a third culture person
i mean i'm a u.s citizen i've been spent
my whole life adult life in the u.s but
at any point if i'm critical about the
us and i am on many occasions they would
say well
go back to where you came from kind of
response i mean not maybe not in the
same way
and that is a similar lack of capacity
to kind of
endure
a
critique and a way to kind of say we got
to move forward
but i want to switch more to uh
kind of a
less spoken side and bring you on into
this
about loveability now one of the
questions when we reached out and did a
survey and did some questions
anabolically we said we talked about
arts and culture
and we said how much does it matter and
some people came back it's effusive i
love singapore for how much it
celebrates it's other culture i love
kind of the the landscape we built
around it and how we've attracted
uh prominent artists and like all of
these people to come in and build that
for singapore and how we've also
expanded our own and then there were
other responses that said i don't care
for any of it
these museums are built for tourists not
for me i don't ever go to one of these
things it does nothing for me so ivan i
want to pull you arts and culture into
this conversation say how does that
matter for a lovability of a city
yeah well before we get to arts and
culture just struck me listening to to
uh the other panelists too that the
other point of um
kind of where we have conflated things
and i think this is what makes it
difficult is the difference between city
and country you know so so if i if i use
a relationship you know you you date a
guy you like him that's your city but he
comes with a family and that's your
country right and and somehow i think
that's one of the
uh issues here that we we actually have
a very tight country and we don't have
multiple cities through which you can um
disperse your your tensions or you can
disperse your you know the little things
that you may like right you like this
about new york but you may then go to
the west coast or something else
completely different um
here there is that conflation so you
know that question that you had asked me
and i should really have addressed it
who deserves more or less love in
singapore is that you know if you
unfortunately if you have chosen to kind
of marry that singapore you've not
chosen to it comes with a family and
it's a very small and tight family which
means you gotta love that whole darn
thing um who everybody deserves that
love and singing and that's one of the
conundrums um of being in
in
in this country you know so we're not
looking at the lovable city the problem
is we're looking at a lovable country
and it's actually very hard to look at a
lovable country it's a lot easier to
look at you know it's like new york is
is okay now but the whole america with
trump and maybe not right so lovable
cities easier lovable countries a lot
tougher um and
hold on in the context of singapore i
must say like it's a city country right
i mean yeah that's right
together and that's i think that's one
of the tensions here because actually
you do get that diversity and the the
conflicts right between very very
different social demographic groups you
are very different you're clearly you
know both uh lauren and yourself are
very globalized citizens comfortable in
cities but you know we will have another
significant proportion who are different
and and for me i i may be very
comfortable in city i have family
members who are not you know so again um
i think that that helps to or
rather that contributes to some of the
tensions that we are seeing in the
surveys and in the questions but back to
your question arts and culture i think
for me what arts and culture do is it
gives us a language it gives us a
language to talk about who we are
outside of politics um
which dominates in in some countries and
outside of the language of the media
which has always been dominating artists
uh provide a language of conscience
provide a language for us to think about
the past and the future that is actually
independent
of a politicized language or a very
political language or language that is
created for political ends and a
language that is created for
to sell something like i mean at the end
of the day the media wants to sell
something um so i to me that's the heart
of arts and culture not necessarily
seen in the in orchestras or ballet
companies or whatever
exported
but the tools it then gives a country
and its people to be able to express
itself in song and poetry
in you know
uh
street culture in dances at weddings in
songs in churches or you know just stuff
that you speak and you wrap out your
emotions or your aspirations outside of
political language and outside of a very
media contained language and i think in
some ways it therefore is a more
authentic language
so it is a bridge and it is something
that cuts across many different across
across age groups across all the
different
uh markers we have to separate each
other now you had two images to share
would any of those be relevant in the
context of this conversation yeah yeah
okay so i'm so sorry uh i don't want to
be talking too much but i'll just call
out those two images so that the
secretary can do that um and i think
that addresses some of these questions
that folks have been posting about
generational differences you know who is
involved you know when the esplanade was
built the architects uh half of them
were british
and you know they built this and you see
this image architecturally i would say
lovely you know it's got nice lines it
lets in the light
um
it's got these triangles that mimic the
dome but it's an empty space it's a cold
and empty space and i think our
responsibilities
to make this space and in some ways the
country lovable is in the next slide um
and and actually what you know the
aspinate and it's 20 years have been
doing is to turn that space into simply
a space where different people gather i
mean this is the image of um a senior's
festival that we do call a date with
friends right so there was a question
about generational differences and we
always think that oh people you know
they don't express their love you come
to a festival like this and you get
aunties and uncles in their 60s playing
the ukulele you know and they are having
a party they will sing along and they
would dance along but
at the heart of it you know
who do you make the space for
who do you want to come into your
country is your country or your space
able to reflect the goals the dreams the
aspirations the messiness of life if you
will of all these
different people who come and are you
actually able to contain that and accept
that you know the reality is you know we
talk about homelessness as well i think
somebody mentioned that
i have i know maybe three homeless semi
i don't really know if they're homeless
they're always hanging around they
aspinate with their bags you know they
watch all our free performances they sit
they use our toilets we know them by by
name i think some of our staff know them
very well and they love being in this
center they're just comfortable they're
not judged and i do think this is the
space that the arts allow because
unlike other public spaces artists
folks of those of us who work in culture
our our instincts are to empathize and
to want to
relate in in whatever way you come to us
in
so that's my long short answer it covers
i guess several aspects of uh what julia
you have
yeah yeah
no it is true and then there's a
reflection i mean what you said about
the us and it's
um
it's a far cry from the country i went
to you know 25 years ago
and but at the same point we were in san
francisco we took to the streets for
many of these issues including with our
three kids
and there was a sense of connection as
an agency that came with that
a sense that you had a say that
that
is um structurally missing
in singapore
there are many other positive
but um i want to switch to some of the
audience questions this is again a part
this is our um with this project with
this effort this initiative is our first
kind of uh opening it up to the public
some great questions so i'm going to
pull in some of these questions so one
of the questions is could the panelists
share their thoughts on the loving
critic argument by professor tommy cole
i'm not as familiar with this but i
could i could presume what it is
do you think that the more someone loves
the city country the more the critic
tends to be
or the opposite end uh someone else who
doesn't love the city country would be
a pathetic discussion about its state uh
i've read some of uh professor kohl's
stuff i i like it it's definitely
on the provocative edge and some of the
discourse that's needed
anyone want to take a step at that to
start off
on the loving critic
and the role of the loving critic
i can take a short answer on that and it
comes from where we operate
uh from with all of our cities and that
is absolutely but that is that is true
it needs to be done um the criticism
needs to come from a place of love and a
place that is also as i mentioned
earlier holistic right not throwing out
you know the flaws
without appreciating where they've come
from and i think you talked about this
before in that tension in singapore
about letting go right because all of
these gains were so hard won and they
are unparalleled right we really can't
take that away from singapore to come so
far and to have crowded in so much value
into such a tiny space and to create a
multicultural society is phenomenal um
and you know i cannot
really find any other example across a
global network of a city who's been able
to deliver that many benefits
at the same time
you know if that becomes complacency
right and sort of that laziness that's
implied by the argument
you lose that
you lose that edge right and the next
generation if they're not
involved in that fight
in in a compelling way
then they would become complacent right
so it's not a either ed you have to be
empowered and i think what's really
impressive
about people like tommy ko and people in
the pioneer generation who get really
fired up is
they love and they care because they
were given
the ability to be part of that
co-creation in a deeply meaningful way i
mean you know if you talk to um someone
like ty care he is still fired up about
whether or not certain roadways should
be built to accommodate 10 million
people or not and i know that's a very
controversial number right and you know
probably not a number that singapore is
going for but these folks were empowered
so
the question is really where is the
empowerment and i think this goes a bit
to what yvonne was was just talking
about which is is such an amazing
frontier
that singapore has to figure out how you
get that criticism and that energy and
that co-creation
into
the venn diagram between the hard and
soft
because the heart is done very well
and the soft
needs a lot of work
whether that's in the arts or whether
that's in activating communities or
whether that's in community rain gardens
that absorb flood waters because there's
just no way puv can build enough
drainage to deal with climate impacts so
i think that that's where there's a lot
of space for this and you know getting
passionate being that loving critic is
so essential
yeah
i was
um
i don't know what i'm saying whether
it's too too controversial don't take a
step with this
um
the critique typically comes from love
other they wouldn't typically they
wouldn't open their mouth in the first
place
right so i think having the prefix to
say stuff that you know critics should
be loving
was more from nicole's way itself of
basically just saying chill out try and
find some moderation of what you're
saying uh if you can speak from a space
of a larger picture then maybe yourself
like you'll be less you know chastised
but the whole job of the critic is the
profit the profit is never loved in
their own hometown the prophet brings
the end is near the end is near rings
that bell and basically says some
horrible message over here that no one
wants to hear
but the bottom line itself is again this
does this it's not so much the critic
it's the loving audience that i'm
concerned about are we so thin skinned
that we cannot take criticism that we
cannot learn
and i i'm much more concerned about the
audience you know about i don't know the
sensitivity of whoever's listening to
the critic right that's getting all
riled up yeah there and i think it's a
lot to do itself with like even what i
think ivonne must be i imagine dealing
with it on daily basis who do we allow
um what actor or actresses right do we
allow out and what artists do we allow
out but the concern of the artist is
that artists will always have a loving
message the question is whether the
audience is ready for it
right um
so when it comes down to the loving
critique i i don't know it
yeah i i'd rather not go into names or
things like that i think many of the
people who've been speaking about
singapore have been coming from a space
of love yeah and then we question their
love when they when they say something
that's not
you know palatable
that's a reflection of our maturity not
theirs
now
um
if you want to have something to add to
that
no i think they've said most things
that's very well said um there's there's
a another question here and this one
brings back to a conversation we had and
it says hey this this conversation we
brought up relationships in many cases
by the way after this i think many
people are going to choose not to get
married because we brought up all the
baggage that comes with marriage
but uh
but anyway
it there's a choice related to it but
you don't get boundaries so what is the
rest what is the responsibility for
those uh who don't have the choice to
leave
who can just pick up and say this
doesn't work for me i'm gonna make
another choice like if that's not
available to them even you and i talked
about that
want to expand on that
yeah i mean i mean in some ways you know
if i go back to the you you marry
whoever it is or you date wherever you
inherit their baggage right their family
and and
i think most people i i did ask dsg most
people you speak to are people who have
that choice they can choose to love
singapore or be that loving critic or
live in whichever city they want to and
occasionally come back and still profess
a love uh we are highly mobile but
there's a large number of people in this
country who cannot leave this country
what does it mean what are their views
you know what do they love
about about singapore who
who
loves them back
what what is the country's
responsibility in loving them back
with or without their contribution i
think those are the responsibilities
of folks
i speak you know some we've been
educated we
benefited from the system um that's our
responsibility
constantly to to to see how is it that
you then take care of the rest of the
clan if you will the rest of the family
you know because if nothing else you
first loved your whoever you married
right and you then
you then extend that love to everybody
else and i i that is the real question
you know how do we love um the very
weakest in the country
uh how how do we choose to love the
folks who seem to be politically very
extreme and radical uh the folks who
speak the harshest things and we don't
agree with i think those are the
questions as a city or
maybe a country we will need to address
and the the arts confronts these issues
all the time
i was going to say this is a really good
space for arts to come into play
uh and just for context for the audience
you know in this conversation we really
stretched a lot in the sense of what is
love what does it mean to be a lovable
city or a country
why does it even matter
in the second conversation the second
webinar it will be much more tactical
okay
all this talk is great but what do you
do about it how does it manifest in the
city itself so the partners in this
study include ura and mccy they are
going to take input from the study to
say well okay where does place making
come into play so into a context of art
art could be really brought in to a way
that it can help bridge some of the gaps
that exist today and to tongi's work on
with common ground and the thought
collective areas there could be a lot
that could be brought in
from kind of the findings from this work
that gets manifested in kind of the
day-to-day lives
yeah i might in some ways it is a social
question we built our best design spaces
you know duxton right in the middle of
the city right
um you you take three minutes drive down
you're in bukit mira red hill
and gang's there right or lots of old
people or take the other direction
you're at chinsui lots of old people who
live there as well now the measure of
the city is how we should be spending
more time
more monies more energy bettering those
communities and they are living in
physical spaces
if you know obviously ideally we
shouldn't have to choose but
uh i think the measure of the strength
of a country is therefore then what is
bukit mera like and what is ginsui like
and how are we making the lives of the
people there better that will make this
city a whole lot more lovable
or rather it will not make it may or may
not make the city livable but it will
show that the city has love
yeah
all right i want to come back to you
you mentioned a few cities barcelona
kyoto milan new york
and then prior conversation mentioned
lagos
do any of these other cities
showcase
the conversations we had today around
vulnerability authenticity trust
agency
do they do it well what can we learn
from them
absolutely i mean all of these cities
and again it comes back to this parallel
between resilience and love all of these
cities have been working with us on a
resilience plan that by definition
is inclusive and by definition is
holistic so when when we look at
planning from a resilience perspective
we always look at four dimensions we
always look at health and well-being so
those basic needs we always look at
economy and society and encompassing
issues like yvonne was just talking
about is where are our most vulnerable
citizens is their social mobility are
their neighbors taking care of neighbors
infrastructure environment so those
infrastructure services are we taking
care of nature are do they have a
supportive or destructive relationship
and then leadership and strategy so how
are we actually building that pipeline
how are we involving people in the
discussion about the future and how
solid is our vision do we have the right
institutional capacity to carry it out
so
in in that vein when we work with each
of these cities
we create a committee
right to do the resilience plan and to
check it
right so that committee has to have
representation from youth from arts from
the private sector it's not a all
government committee
with a representative from each
department
it might
start there but it needs to at least be
double that size right because it
actually needs to look like your city
looks
um and you also have to
think about what your city will look
like right if your city is a very young
city then you need to have more youth
representation if your city is an aging
city then you need to think more about
that as well
and so
in that vein these cities take it very
very seriously to be inclusive and to
have a real conversation about what's
going to build their resilience and have
people in love right and involved in in
that strategy and i can share actually
in the chat with the group members there
is a phenomenal youtube video um that
our chief resilience officer from lagos
just posted this weekend about their
strategy and you can see
the different people in the video
talking about what the strategy means to
them
and why it gives them hope
about their city which is a mega city
with lots and lots of challenges but
they talk openly about it and they talk
about what they're going to do about it
and how those priorities
have been derived through an inclusive
process and that's really key to to
going forward you know you can't build
love you can't build loveability you
cannot build resilience without having
an open and inclusive conversation and
prioritizing things from a
differentiated group of stakeholders
that reflects the citizenry of your city
whatever we built here as a framework to
test lavability of the city i'd love to
come back to you and extend it to these
other cities and see
uh how it works over there so um we're
coming to the close of our conversation
i'm going to continue with a few more
questions with the pandas that came up
here and i want to get that kind of
closing thoughts but uh there's some
great questions from the audience i want
to go back to those as well but we also
want to open up a polling question to
the audience you've been amazing in
writing things on as you came along i'd
love for you to take this final poll as
we continue this conversation so can we
put up the the mentee uh code for this
um
what is it or who have we missed out in
our discussion today like i said this is
the beginning of a much bigger longer
discussion so what have we not talked
about what have we missed what did we
not say what did we not talk about what
should we explore more
um add those all in there's a qr code
that's going to come in
next and that's the mentee if you go to
mentee.com and put in that code 9051
5952 to put it in so this is going to go
on in the background it's in your chat
as well so work on that and as you fill
in your answers it'll pop up in a word
cloud but as we go to that i want to um
i have a few more questions here from
the audience and i'll bring to our
panelists
um it says okay it feels a lot like the
factors of a club that are quite out of
the regular citizens hands is there
anything that the ordinary person living
in singapore can do to foster
loveability for the city that's a very
good
question that we should all have a
simple answer to what can all of us like
there's a sense of what can i do
right so
can i get some responses i'd love to get
a response there for each of you
in terms of
what the day-to-day person can do to
make singapore more lovable
i'm just giving i don't know
can you go first
uh everyday people
in a lot of the work you do to
facilitate
um
sorry
before we go into the how i think we
need to establish the what
again so a lot of the times over here
citizens keep asking how do we do this
how do we do that how do we you know you
know run out over the case i'm not
really sure that we have yet to
establish for ourselves as a country of
what is the way forward or what is the
new narrative
the whole singapore third world to first
story has expired some time ago already
but yet we don't have a new vision a new
expiration point so what exactly the
city is about what exactly is this
country about
and i think we've had some attempt at
being saying singapore together but
that's a mechanism it's not a vision
the mechanism itself of us coming
together is basically how we're going to
do it we're going to do it together but
where are we going
i don't know
so
the thing about this over there is that
the what question needs to be answered
and i think citizens need to come to the
table to speak about this
um i'm not sure itself right whether or
not singapore's yet all these
singaporeans are yet aware of the fact
that
um this is a political conversation but
it's not a
one that political leaders can answer
not at this stage of our development
yeah
it is a politician it's a conversation
that all of us need to begin to voice
out just say over here so what's the
next phase and what's the next step
yeah and we've had the tradition of
multiple prime ministers before that
always defining for us what the next
step is
but i'm suspecting itself right at 50
years on forwards over here no prime
minister no matter how freaking charming
they are over here can actually name
this question our country is diverse and
is mature and as affluent as our own
so if citizens want to start playing a
part um open your mouth
we really need the understanding of what
is next yeah and that's something
even as a facilitator i have the energy
to bring people to the table but i can't
do the work for them
okay so i do have an outstanding
challenge one of the top things that
came up in this world club as you see is
freedom of speech
how do they open their mouth where do
they say something do they become a
netizen like what's their where's their
space
and this could actually overlap with
arts but how do they open their mouth
where do they have a say
you know it's something that i have a i
don't know okay so this could be my own
privilege speaking i'm not so sure with
whether i'm i name this right
um
the horrible culture we have over
defamation suits and gunners whatever
lawsuits that come around uh have
largely been around uh malignment or
some kind of defamation right
i don't think i have seen opinions other
people express necessarily becoming a
legal issue
okay
yeah so i know that actually all sorts
of controversial is being said at
esplanade all the time but i'm not sure
everyone goes to court for it
yeah
and in doing so over here
i i don't know i i say a lot of horrible
things all the time over here i don't go
to
jail for it but that's why i don't know
whether it's a reflection my own
privilege
right such that i don't get nailed to
the cross
um
but i don't know
i i i put it out as an idea i think you
can nail one to two people on the cross
and people will be scared enough i'm not
sure you can nail 10 000 people to the
cross
yeah so your call your response to that
question is speak up
what you can do every day as an everyday
citizen is to speak up to have a voice
what is the vision what is the vision
that we're heading towards
yeah what do you want for singapore yeah
yeah ivan lauren
well you know that vision is is of
course uh something which
in the political context that's your
highest level of leadership right and as
a voter you influence that debate um you
know um the
tongi spoke about uh whether all kinds
of gets spoken in the aspinate i'm
sure i mean the reality is the arts
provide that safe space but you know
what it the that gets spoken is
also in context
now that it makes a big difference when
you when you
put that out i'm sorry you know you
know it's all about context in a theater
space
the context is that it's a safe space
the lights darken
you know we we have um agreement with
the other person who has bought a ticket
that we we are here because we want to
be challenged or we want to listen to
something we you know we may not agree
but we all agree this is the space we're
in and i think part of the political
debate is also about context of speaking
you writing something on your random
facebook
versus you you know uh
signing up for a political party and and
i think we really need to understand the
context for for conversations better and
then be able to construct rules around
those contexts of conversation and that
brings me to my my my third point which
is what does the ordinary singaporean do
if you are not necessarily voting every
five years because you have to wait five
years right or you're not going to run
for whatever party what is there left
for you to do and i think the context is
if we shrink the city
expand it it's the country but if you
shrink the city down
you're then in your neighborhood
i know i've lived in torpyo for the last
maybe 15 years i live in a you know a
four-room hdb flat um i'm i love torpyo
right and what i do then as a citizen
because it's an extension of my love for
the city or the country is i'm as
friendly as i can be to my neighbor um i
you know i if i see somebody or in my
blog
i always try to say hello i form
relationships with my community i speak
of it if i find something good about in
my neighborhood that i can love about it
i tell somebody else it's the same in
your in your relationship right if you
love your partner and you find somebody
something good about your partner you
are boasting about it all the time to
somebody else if you find the flaw you
kind of you know i got tons of rats in
at one point in in dropayo there were a
lot of rats right what did i do i wrote
a note because i couldn't take it it's
like look this is singapore we cannot be
having rats around so i you know i i
went up to the mp or whatever you you
can in your community do something so i
think the city is somewhere in between
the country of course is where you get
political discourse but for the ordinary
singaporean and i i see that you don't
need to be educated i've got you know
family members who are not terribly
educated they love living in singkang
they are always telling me to go seng
kang to eat this or that or to visit
them you know but i think we do need to
think of our neighborhoods not as
investments and not measured purely by
its economic status um and then i think
you you will think roots and once you
sink roots which is some somebody asked
that question right mistress or wife uh
once you are committed to that
you kind of are false because your fate
is intertwined with that community uh
you cannot
just simply
step away i for me i like i'm thinking
really hard but moving out of top io you
know it's like every time somebody says
hey look there's a flat available here
come and stay near me i'm like no i want
to live in topaio but that that comes
from a lot of uh
roots if you will and investments i have
made in the relationships uh
acknowledged or otherwise
with this this town so
i do think the ordinary singaporean can
do that keep your town clean don't
litter be friendly to your neighbor all
that is part of the next that those are
loving acts i think these are very
loving acts i agree then those are very
simple ones
okay so tommy speak out ivan be loving
to your neighbor speak out about what
you love you have something to add tangy
could you just give me a minute lauren
do you mind just giving me a minute
before you go for it yeah thank you so
much i i just want to make sure i i
squeeze this in it's um
i'm gonna die if i don't say it um it
was basically the what yvonne was saying
around context and uh i wanted to speak
on behalf of the social sector of what
is it that we are seeing on the ground
uh around basically
how citizens can begin to really
contribute and work right
with a as a nation as young as ours and
as fast-moving as ours i think we have
not found a good space for grief and
loss
we have not found the space that if we
are as progressive and as fast-moving as
we are they will be lost along the way
right we don't have a space to speak
about miscarriages we don't have a space
to speak about suicide of our children
we don't have a space itself to speak
about childless couples or retrenchment
or loss of heritage right or any other
things itself right that come about as a
result of actually our living right and
in doing so over here i'm getting a
sense over here that a lot of the
anxiety and anger that we're expressing
to currently in singapore the context is
sadness the context is lost it's not
that singapore is angry and singapore
itself is furious in talking about all
things singapore just needs closure only
singaporeans need closure in multiple of
the things that they think that they
have paid for right it's a very heavy
price of it
and this goes back a lot to what i said
earlier there's some things we don't
dare talk about but i think that if we
don't talk about them there isn't the
space for that closure to happen right
and it's quite critical i think that we
open up a particular space so if there's
one thing that singaporeans can do is
learn to open space for one another
learn to help people close in the issues
that they begin to deal with on a daily
basis
um i know the social sector is actually
really quite struggling but the data is
all over the country we can see it yeah
and yes it's coming out in terms of
mental health issues and so and so forth
in terms of a lot of angry speech
i think it's far more easy to present
anger than to present sadness yeah okay
my apologies mental health issues was
the number one thing here i do have an
addon to that but lauren please love
your last word on in terms of what could
everyday singaporean do to make the city
more lovable
it's it's really hard to follow two
singaporeans as a as a
non-singaporean and
you know looking at the list of issues
there
it just brings me back to the fact that
even the concept of resilience comes
from a space of ecology and
and psychology right and and
being able to
deal with difficulty and spring forward
and and making the spaces then what
tongue he said was
very very beautiful about that and i
think
if if there's any
kind of last word about that
i will actually end unfortunately with a
bit of a management cliche
um and that is show me your your budget
and i'll tell you what your values are
and singapore has been calling this
recovery from covid19 the resilience
budget
um the investments should accrue
to spaces
that need this kind of empathy
because singapore has created some of
the most amazing
um you know urban advisory servant
jurang or
companies like zintel or others that
serve
purposes of creating building blocks for
a very high powered high-tech city and a
smart city
um now for that resilient lovable
compassionate city you know it's time to
invest in that kind of a connective
tissue
because where you invest you will create
innovation you will create space
and your younger singaporeans will have
the ability to be the vanguard of these
new industries that we as humanity so
desperately need
so your call to action is for the
government
to
or or public private partnerships right
create incentives for people to work
together on these issues because they
are happening in other places right you
you see collaboration coming into
singapore on health issues some of these
mental health issues already have rich
collaboration here in singapore so maybe
it's time to double down on those maybe
it's time to really look at where those
opportunities are in higher relief
and and and lauren can i just ask a
question and in some ways i'm echoing
the questions from a couple of folks who
have typed their quest um written down
the u.s you know kind of um resident but
non-citizen
resident in singapore do you feel this
discussion means something different to
you
because you have various home countries
you are highly mobile professionals um
you know
uh do you feel pushed away by kind of
recent political debate about citizens
versus non-citizens just curious and do
you really seriously believe that a city
or a country can be lovable and if it
has a very high proportion of of um
uh
resident
you know non-citizen
wealthy
educated
uh people like yourselves just curious
let me
be frank both both of your views and and
your experiences uh having looked at you
know cities like london
uh
maybe one called we are up on we are out
of time but
i don't want to avoid the question at
all i would say like as a
i mean as as a permanent resident and as
a mother of two semi-singaporeans as
they call them i feel extremely invested
in singapore and to be very honest
i think this is one of the best places
to
to live and to
to do the best so i feel very invested
in that at the same time it's been so
interesting during the last election to
see um you know the debate around
foreigners coming in and i actually
think it's really natural
i kind of welcome it to be out in the
open and be a discussion because
if there are two candidates competing
for a job and you have a fantastic local
candidate why would you bring in a
foreigner right and i
love working with singaporeans we're
hiring which is a shout out um so i'd
love to hire more young singaporeans
who want to work on issues of resilience
and cities um both here in singapore and
in the region
so i think it's a healthy conversation
when i look around singapore and i see
older singaporeans who have to work well
into their old age just to make it you
know i think these are things that we
all see we all observe and we need to
create spaces to talk about and we as
foreigners are a big percentage of the
population and so there has to be a
conversation about how to prioritize
that and and how to make the best of
different talents and different groups
in in any city and it's very very common
so i think that's the other thing that i
would point out is that cities attract
large groups of immigrants from lots of
different places and we get back into
that conversation about city and country
um and and scale um but i think it's a
very natural conversation it's a
conversation that should be had and i
don't um as a as a foreigner as pr
living here have any issue um engaging
in that debate with friends family and
colleagues
thank
you um so
we are out of time so i'm going to give
a quick answer off like uh in setting up
the center for the age i was debating
between
tokyo shanghai beijing hong kong and
singapore and cho singapore in some part
for personal reasons like i said my wife
is from here but also
because um there's a lot going on here
there's a lot to go for singapore so
longer conversation i want to hand it
back to janine um this has been
wonderful thank you lauren tony and ivan
thank you
thank you the audience you guys have
been great there's lots of questions we
didn't get to answer we'll try to answer
them
i think all of us are very findable we'd
be happy to share our information if you
want to follow up with any of us
uh tangy we're gonna talk about bringing
burning man or something similar to
singapore because that is a festival of
flipping orthodoxies and allowing people
a space to be themselves and to to
grieve and to let go and to
open up and we can create a lot of that
and yvonne will be a big part of it
because she's leaving that janine back
to you thank you so much everyone
everybody thank you so much for this
really robust and
exciting conversation
uh i just want to do a quick shout out
for the second webinar which will be
happening on the 30th of september
and that's a follow-up to this webinar
where we will be gathering
design and urban practitioners
to
discuss and deliberate how we can
practically build the future of
livability in singapore so please
please join us engage with us on our
social media channels to get the
invitation
and also
we would love to hear your feedback
about this webinar so on your screen
there are now two qr codes on the left
it links to a quick post event survey
and that link can also be found in the
zoom chat
uh your answers will really help us to
build better programs for you in the
future and on the right if you'd like to
find out more about programs the
national design center has lined up
under the theme singapore our home just
head over to the qr code on the right
so again uh thank you so much delisha
yvonne yee and lauren for the wonderful
conversation
and to everybody who attended and is
still with us
thank you for sharing your evening with
us so good night and
um if you if anybody wants to re-watch
this um webinar we'll be posting it on
youtube in
in a few days time so thank you and see
you soon
you